hello there I do not give a [ __ ] what
anyone says pod racing is badass it's
like [ __ ] F0 and burnout was Jaja
things that bad
welcome back to this episode of trash
taste I'm Connor wearing a brand new
shirt with Joey and gone hello there
sorry dude hello there stop saying hello
there hello there Jerry since Joey said
that I'm like [ __ ] I love that sound I
don't Perpetual in it one thing I've
always wanted is like what why were
prequel memes just why how did they just
become a thing because you know with
stop with SpongeBob because they're just
good movies are they though because
that's everyone [ __ ] haters are very
good yeah and they they've they've been
something that have just like stayed
throughout you know I think that three
pools are better than the modern
Star Wars I haven't seen any of the
modern ones I've only seen one and I do
like it seven well did you did you watch
did you watch the pre-chord like when
they came out I don't know if you are
okay yeah I don't [ __ ] know man well
okay no I was very young so yeah yeah
yeah
what year did episode want to start I
remember the singly being like ten yeah
and my cousin dragged me on drag me I
wanted to go went to the theater to
watch Return of the Sith is that the
name return Revenge of the Sith yeah I
think you just mixed up about like three
movies you missed the Return of the Jedi
with Revengers which is the third one
six right
[Music]
modern one okay so episode one came out
1999. I remember watching that when I
was like four or five one like DVD or
VHS yes back then yeah and then I went
to the theater to watch revenge of the
city yeah yeah yes episode three just
episode three yeah three and I remember
that I didn't really know what the [ __ ]
was happening yeah because he missed
Clone Wars right yeah I think I watched
Clone Wars I don't know when but I
remember just I was I I was too young to
follow the right storyline of Star Wars
I just like the the shootie and the
lightsaber which is honestly I mean
that's yeah
when I was a little older and I didn't
care yeah like I remember the first Star
Wars I actually watched in theaters was
the Clone Wars I remember watching as a
teenager and just seeing like so many
Jedis seeing [ __ ] Samuel Jackson's
Mace Windu [ __ ] Yoda tearing [ __ ] up
I'm like this is amazing and then I
talked to my older cousin about it and
it's like the [ __ ] I'm like okay I guess
this [ __ ] I'm too good oh yeah because I
was the exact same way with episode one
because I was just like damn this is
[ __ ] insane the pod racing Darth
vadas the fight with him and uh what's
his name the Gotham no sorry Darth Maul
sorry like the Darth Maul fight with uh
[ __ ] uh yeah yeah that's the guy
who's done that I don't know Qui-Gon Jin
why do I [ __ ] know that yeah Liam
Neeson I think that like so you will
Darth Maul yeah oh yeah that [ __ ]
scene where he gets the [ __ ] double
lightsaber out as a kid that was the
coolest [ __ ] ever I remember me it was
just the music I remember this one this
one cup that my me and my cousin like
recreated because we thought it was like
the OG Star Wars kid I I was I was okay
because because we saw the uh we saw the
Darth Maul versus Obi-Wan and Mace Windu
fight right sure it was badass yeah that
[ __ ] was bad oh sorry no no no no uh no
he he fought both of them right yeah he
did yeah did he yeah
listen if you don't know dies yeah if
you don't even know that name then no he
doesn't find Mace Windu does he no no
sorry Darth Maul versus Qui-Gon Jinn
yeah and Obi-Wan yeah yeah yeah and then
well it makes it sound like a [ __ ]
anime fight yo
yo top 10 characters that could be Goku
but I remember there's this one shot uh
where it's just Darth Maul versus
Obi-Wan and I think oh [ __ ] Obi-Wan's
got the disadvantage because Darth was
got a double double-ended lightsaber how
can he compare there's one really cool
shot where Obi-Wan blocks the lightsaber
with one with like okay so Darth Maul
tries to swing him he blocks with it
like that and then he goes he puts it
behind him and blocks him like when the
choice is like stab his back and I'm
like that is one of the coolest shots
ever and me and my cousin would just
recreate the whole [ __ ] Darth Maul
fight in our bedroom like oh this is
this is bringing back so many memories
now when you say when you say replicate
did you mean like you don't mean like
[ __ ] professional grade like
choreography right like you just mean
you just [ __ ] whacked each other oh
no we we whacked each other's with
sticks okay that's that's what I mean we
whacked each other's sticks we worked
each other's whip sticks but who who
didn't who didn't when they saw
something cool when you were first kid
you know I mean you know I'm sure me and
my sister as well also replicated that
fight but it was just me going
replicate was just as I'm doing this
with the double-ended stay it's just me
going
yeah yeah I think as a kid it was just
cool it's [ __ ] cool like do you think
because everyone's [ __ ] on the new
Trilogy now do you reckon there's going
to be a time where the the new Trilogy
memes just kind of surface because
everyone everyone [ __ ] on the
prequels and as a kid I thought they
were everyone [ __ ] on them OG Star Wars
fans if it felt like it was just common
senses to be like yeah the prequels they
suck yeah they ruined episode episode
four to six fans said that one to three
[ __ ] yeah yeah like I I that was the
consensus when I was like growing up
well like I I kind of like the prequels
but everyone around me is uh saying
their [ __ ] and so I was like young I was
like I guess I guess I just have bad
taste I guess it's [ __ ] I guess yeah I
still thought pod racing was one of the
coolest things ever yeah that's watching
watching because I watched the original
not the original Three that second
episode wave second draw I don't know
one two three one to three I watched one
to three first all right right and I
almost feel like it made it more
interesting because I had no idea that
Luke was gonna turn up Luke yeah Luke I
had no idea that Anakin was going to
turn to a bad guy holy [ __ ] so you
actually were just like oh my God
I'm like I'm like that's [ __ ] sick
they made like the main guy into the bed
no I I feel you because I was the exact
same one like no other teams were doing
that yeah when I was a kid so he was
like whoa no I I had I was even more
primitive in my understanding of Star
Wars because like yeah the first one I
ever watched was one and then I was like
oh they have like up to three so I'm
like I'll watch three yeah and then at
the end of three I was like oh oh
there's a fourth one oh [ __ ] that must
be new and I looked at I'm like what
does it look so good yeah
why are all the Jedi's just like [ __ ]
they're not like dancing around anymore
yeah like what happened like jumping
around they're just standing still I'm
like what happened man the quality
really went down after episode three
you're getting the watch orders should
start with episode one do you think
that's why it's one that's why we call
it one
why did George Lucas decide to start
with four
um I don't know because because when the
movie came out it was called Star Wars
episode four yeah yeah I mean he must
have actually yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like when it first ever came out it
didn't become episode four after one and
three came out it started off this
episode four yeah that's I'm fairly
serious recipe for disaster now yeah he
must have had some big [ __ ] balls to
be like guys this is episode four in the
second Trilogy and then all the
producers are like uh George have you
have you figured out what one to three
is he's like no I'll be honest I don't
know enough about George Lucas and and
all of Star Wars production to know what
the [ __ ] happened no yeah I'm sure there
are a bunch of people in the comments
who know yeah I don't know one one thing
one one story I've always liked is like
everyone who acted on the original Star
Wars they thought it was a good [ __ ] it
was like [ __ ] they thought it wasn't
going to be good yeah yeah exactly
because they were like because at the
time it was so far beyond any kind of
film convention because back back then
Star Wars did so much revolutionize the
uh sci-fi just genre in general so I I
just can't imagine what the axes were
like being like okay so we're just like
they're looking at this green screen so
and George Lucas is like okay just
pretend that we're going into hyperspace
and it just must have felt like a bunch
of [ __ ] gibberish back then could you
imagine like [ __ ] Harrison Ford's
just being like so I have to act with
this [ __ ] guy in a furry costume the
entire time are you [ __ ] kid he
doesn't talk I like it because Harrison
Ford always just acts like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] no I said I'm just like oh
everyone's like that's such a great
character that's unfortunately I just I
just generally that's just him I
genuinely just didn't give a [ __ ] he did
seem pretty happy in like Indiana Jones
in that era and then like modern
Harrison Ford just you does not want to
be honest oh my God he's he's the he's
he's the epitome of like Jaden I love
yeah I love that because obviously
spoilers for the new Star Wars because I
I haven't seen it but I know this
happens good I mean it listen there's
only one way of getting Harrison Ford
back and that's if you literally kill
the man which is what he begged them I
believe like this interviews he's like
yeah I only would come back if they
would kill my character really yeah yeah
wow because he wanted to be done with it
oh yeah I mean yeah understandable like
and I think he's too busy like flying
planes or something I think he crashed a
plane he's he's like he's like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's made his money like do you
think people will like that in the MCU
as well where it's just like please
please kill me Chris yeah [ __ ]
beginning okay okay yeah probably I
think oh brother Jr
but also
you know everyone's like bro this guy
didn't take a picture with me at a
convention this YouTube was an [ __ ]
bro have you heard the stories about
Harrison Ford with fans no no he's
[ __ ] mean like he I swear there's so
many [ __ ] stories I gotta look them
up there's so many [ __ ] it just seems
like an [ __ ] I I don't you know
there's actors that you can Envision
being at a fan meeting and like having a
really positive experience yeah like you
know uh I don't know Tom Hiddleston or
something right and then there are
people that you just like I could never
imagine you being at a concert but but
the thing is if if even if you have a
negative experience at Harrison Ford in
my mind that's still a positive
experience because you got to meet Aaron
no no because I'm like yo Harrison Ford
told me to [ __ ] off so in character man
that's exactly what I expect from
Harrison Ford online assistant like oh
he sees his fans as customers but not
like an insulting word it's just like
how he views it obviously I can in some
senses I'm like I respect you to just be
like yeah [ __ ] it yeah you're all
customers it's not beating around the
[ __ ] yeah but I think he hates Star
Wars fans like I think he I think he
like legitimately doesn't like Star Wars
I probably would hate Star Wars fans too
if I was Harrison honestly and I I in my
mind I'm like yeah I I could I could
definitely understandable yeah
understand yo especially like OG Star
Wars fans you know the OG days where
Star Wars just became a popular [ __ ]
Mega hit imagine going to conventions
and actually just meeting Comic Book Guy
except it's not like a parody it's
actually just Comic Book Guy you know
he's done like so many films in like how
many goddamn years and for the past 40
years he's he's [ __ ] he's handsome
that's that's and that must drive I
would drive anyone crazy yeah it's Han
Solo and Indiana Jones right yeah and
then people forget that he was in I
don't know like [ __ ] uh but one of
the Articles was like why does Harrison
Ford hate Star Wars fans are not Indiana
Jones fans well because Indiana Jones
fans on is rabid but I mean they're
normies yeah
right I mean I mean Star Wars fans are
also there's different level of Star
Wars fans there's the Casual Star Wars
fan casual I just like the Lego games
and yeah that was good yeah there's lots
of interesting things about Star Wars
definitely no it's weird now because it
feels like Star Wars it used to be just
Star Wars was just the mainline film
Trilogy that was it that was that was
like the only way to really enjoy Star
Wars but now there's so much Star Wars
meteor out there that I don't even know
where to start because Disney paid a lot
of money and they want them no exactly
they want that [ __ ] money back and
they're gonna milk every goddamn facet
of Star Wars yeah this is just the
beginning I think I think we're in like
phase one of their like phase one of
their like 20 face I'm I'm waiting Star
Wars milking project I'm waiting for a
Chewbacca backstory movie uh it's well
we're gonna if we haven't had one
already I'm telling you here's what's
gonna happen clip this in five years
when it becomes relevant it's gonna be
an animation movie of Chewbacca where
it's like all cutesy and Chewbacca
doesn't really talk and it's gonna be
like a silent movie and they're gonna
merchandise the [ __ ] out of it there's
gonna be baby
it's gonna be like a silent animation
movie or baby Yoda was already a thing
yeah they're gonna make him like super
marketable because they learned from
baby Yoda and they're like if we just
make it like a kind of Minion Vibe yeah
they're gonna turn Chewbacca into
minions and I'm telling you there's
nothing you can do about it and it's
gonna happen oh my God it's like me yeah
this is gonna happen I'm telling you
it's like minions and Furbies and when
it happens come back to this trash Test
episode and be like wow this aged
amazingly well poorly depending on what
poorly yeah good or good old Disney
there's no way they're doing something
with Chewbacca's right as a Chewbacca
movie and you're not making it animated
yeah think about it the suits look too
ugly
not not marketable enough for kids
that's true it's like look look what
they did with uh like the the recent
Disney remakes where they're remaking
old classics
yeah like Beauty and the Beast and stuff
yeah I hate that [ __ ] I know right like
have you have you guys has anyone seen
like The Lion King or anything yeah
that's all what I forgot about that I
saw it in cinemas I blocked that from my
memory I started Cinemas because I was
just I mean [ __ ] love Lion King so I
was just like I am just morbidly curious
if this is even gonna be remotely good
it was the most like if I could just
like I've never met a movie I've never
seen a movie and just immediately
thought uncanny valley yeah like I don't
I'm like I don't know I'm not a fan of
lions smiling because they made the
lines look realistic yeah it's like that
you know before they also kind of gave
them human emotional faces as well so
it's like there's just like lions
Greening and like scolding and [ __ ] I'm
just like lions don't do that it's kind
of it's kind of like you know when uh
before Paramount fixed the Sonic movie
dude remember like the first Sonic
trailer where you have like [ __ ]
teeth and it just looked like uh a
[ __ ] lovecraftian nightmare creature
[ __ ] like that you know it's like a Thor
yeah right
yeah because like I watched like a few
clips of Aladdin and I'm just like damn
obviously now it's cool to hear on Will
Smith and everything but um he just like
you can't replace Robin Williams as the
genie like Will Smith Will Smith was the
charismatic guy although to be fair the
only redeemable Factor about that movie
is also
let's not forget Mulan oh I didn't even
bother watching oh yeah I did did you
watch it no it was but like I mean I
mean it got absolutely [ __ ] it was it
was like it was it was bound to fail
before it even came of course there's a
[ __ ] ton of controversies yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah just like every single live
action they've touched as like either
boring or just actually [ __ ] yeah like
Beauty and the Beast was probably the
one where I'm just like okay I can see
this kind of working and I watched it
I'm like okay it wasn't [ __ ] horrible
but I would much rather just watch the
original I watched 30 minutes of it on a
plane and I I was like I can't yeah I'll
keep watching this yeah I don't know I
just a lot of the Disney movies is like
all right okay I think I hit me up and
take my money yeah I think with Beauty
and the Beast they just like they kind
of just like use the [ __ ] just look
just rob me I'm [ __ ] tired of Disney
like setting out an intricate trap to
make everyone go and spend their money
just rob me just [ __ ] take my money I
don't care anymore all these movies suck
I know I know they suck they do they do
now they own everything didn't they also
do a live-action Jungle Book as well
yeah they did yeah but it's not released
I didn't watch that no I didn't watch
that either I I mean didn't hear a lot
about it what are you forgettable they
make their money and they die yeah
that's true what I never understand
right is that there's this mentality
where you know you have a you have an
animated film like Jungle Book like Lion
King but it doesn't become legitimized I
guess until you make it in life actually
yeah and it's not just it's not just you
know Disney cartoon as well we can say
the same thing
yeah it's just like okay and anime's
made it one it's got a live-action
adaptation but like The Jungle Book and
the uh Lion King so much animation well
I'd argue it's more of an animation
you just animated it in a realistic yeah
with Lion King it's like 100 CGS it's
CGI like I'm not watching an IRL thing
this is just a [ __ ] risking yeah this is
like the The Uncanny Valley rescape yeah
it is [ __ ] yeah should make something
new for fun it's like Lion King was made
by Ai and it's just like one one thing I
never understood was like why is there
not more of the opposite sense remaking
popular live action films in animation
because I feel like the only one that's
really notable is Spider-Man well it's
because it's because Hollywood doesn't
take a spite of us yeah yeah I mean but
I feel Hollywood doesn't take animation
seriously unless it's Marvel in DC or
Pixar
yeah yeah I mean everything else is just
like it's it's not a real I mean I don't
really count Spider-Man because
Spider-Man is a comic to begin with and
you know there's had plenty of like
cartoon so you're saying something that
has never had any kind of animated like
iteration of it yeah yeah I mean okay
look I see things like you know one of
the only Star Wars media I like is Star
Wars Visions right because Star Wars
Clone Wars Star Wars clone was [ __ ]
hype that was hype you know the anime
tricks does anyone remember the
animatrix of [ __ ] man and that's because
there's like when you i i s like I in my
opinion when you take something that's
animated and translate that into live
action you are actually restricting a
lot of the expression that you can get
away with right because you're taking
something that in a lot of times is
taking place in like a very Fantastical
world where it's not limited by you know
reality you know by the chains of
reality I guess right but when you take
a live something live action and put it
in animation you have so many more ideas
for just so many so many more
opportunities for just whack key ideas
and just wacky visuals and all that kind
of stuff right well that's why like a
lot of the even the modern Pixar films
are just like still you know creatively
like you know sufficient because it's
like yeah as you were saying it's like
you can't have something like [ __ ]
Moana in live action just because like a
lot of those scenes are just like not
going to work or or they're gonna look
really [ __ ] attacking I haven't had
to stop my brain the whole time like
I've seen a lot of live actions porn
it's just all it's on point yeah
I've seen a lot of these things in life
oh oh oh oh yeah you've seen that you've
seen the dozens yeah
translates well to live
actions
yeah did you see like any did you see
like the Halo anime or like the Mass
Effect I heard him so bad the Halo uh TV
show yeah I heard as well is there an
anime for Halo yeah there's like uh
there's Halo Legends which is which is
kind of like the same kind of taking
this franchise and making like an
anthology series of just right different
things about it right I've I've not
actually watched Halo Legends I've heard
it's I've heard mixed things about it
right but it's funny because I remember
watching Star Wars visions and
nothing made me more happy than watching
Star Wars visions and just seeing OG
Star Wars map or OG Star Wars fans just
[ __ ] mold oh you're in the reviews if
you if you go out and read the IG uh I
don't know IMDb reviews of Star Wars
Visions it is so [ __ ] hilarious
because everything they hate Star Wars
Visions for is everything that I love
Star Wars videos yeah it's just
completely different they're like this
isn't this doesn't go along with the
Star Wars Universe they're just using
the force like it's a [ __ ] thing oh
you know the force has rules we we have
we have boundaries here well I think
like the Star Wars Vision showed me that
oh yeah there's so many more other cool
interesting Concepts that you could do
with Star Wars yeah than the current
Star Wars universe exactly but the
samurai one that was [ __ ] hyped
dude [ __ ] that that first episode
with the samurai where she comes out
with this [ __ ] lightsaber umbrella
yeah that's just cool that's cool [ __ ]
man you haven't watched it check it out
yeah it's pretty good very interesting
if you want to see Star Wars like sick
then yeah
Star Wars Alpha [ __ ] Destiny for making
something good
yeah that's that's the thing I'm not I
wouldn't say I'm a Star Wars fan but
there's plenty of Star Wars things that
I like uh yeah but I do agree like I do
hate how underappreciated just animation
has become in Hollywood unless again
it's not Disney or Pixar or no no what
what thing has Disney done recently well
that's what I'm saying they don't even
do animations
yeah yeah turning red oh is that the one
with the the red panda yeah yeah okay I
haven't seen that one you know the main
voice actress watches trash text for
that that movie really really shout out
to you
I love that movie do you actually I
haven't seen it
I'm all now though she posted the plush
of uh because we won one of them in the
cranking videos yeah and she posted I'm
forgetting the name I should I should
know your name I apologize yeah uh she
posted this she said oh my God I want it
and then everything was like that's the
main voice actress for the the character
oh cool I was like oh thanks for
watching the video she's like oh I watch
Trash taste too and I was like what the
[ __ ]
turning red there was enchanto Encanto
Kanto yeah and then they had Encanto and
then I got confused because there was
Encanto and the other
movie that came out right before which
was the other one that was an encounter
about another uh which ones it can't
talk yeah there's two of them there's a
one that we're about death
you if you've not seen encounter it's
the one where you there's like stuff
yeah we don't talk about Bruno you must
have heard that yeah
yeah I think I couldn't escape for a
while yeah basically yeah it's like you
you haven't seen Encanto but you know
you know you know in cancer okay Coco
there's cocoa and in Canada oh I watch
CoCo I'm talking about the uh main
character from turning red watching
trash taste actually had my first I
guess celebrity moment that I haven't uh
that I haven't I don't think I've talked
about in trash the first clout mode yeah
my first class real Cloud moment yeah no
where it's it's it was weird right
because of course it was in LA meeting a
celebrity of course of course yeah
people talk about it all the time yeah
it happened for me once actually and
it's so weird because being on trash
days and talking about guys if you see
me on the street don't be afraid to say
hi I'm not gonna buy you know just come
say hi take a picture I'll sign
something whatever I don't care you know
I've said we've said that so many times
on trash taste yeah but then when it
happened to me on the other side in real
life I I became everything that I warned
against right so me and Sydney were
having lunch in this Cafe in La
um and it was like a Mexican restaurant
or something we were just having like a
quick lunch and a beer there
um and then
Sydney was like is that is that who I
think it is and I turn around I'm like
who are you talking about and she points
to like a table right in the corner yeah
right and she's like I think that's the
waitress from Always Sunny in
Philadelphia which if you haven't
watched Always Sunny in Philadelphia
it's like a sitcom it's one of mine and
Sydney's like favorite sitcoms of all
time
um and there's a character in there
that's not one of the main characters
but kind of like a side character that's
reoccurring and her name's the waitress
and I was like and she points to her and
I'm like [ __ ] that is that is the
waitress yeah and I'm like I'm Sydney
and and we both want to take a picture
we both want to say hi and take a
picture and
I'm like no City
don't don't do this don't do this he's
like I need my clout yeah I need my dose
of clouds I need some clouds I'm
lowering from lack of clout and like for
the first time I I got it I I understood
that feeling now of just like you can't
just go up yeah you can't just go up
because I'm like no we can't go up there
I mean if it's in a restaurant it's a
lot more Awkward yeah yeah obviously and
and also they were sitting right in the
corner as well and me my my brain I've
been I was like I've been here before if
I'm seeing in the corner I don't want to
be noticed and she was sitting in the
corner table on the corner of the corner
table so I'm like no I can't do it I
can't go up though I can't go up there
but luckily Sydney being the [ __ ]
Giga Chad being like go on I'll do it
I'll [ __ ] do it step aside herbivore
I will do it I will do it and like
Sydney no Cindy stop don't do it and
then she walks up and she says yeah can
I get a picture and of course it was it
was exactly that it was everything that
I said would happen which is of course
she was more than happy she was like
very excited to take a picture I'm just
like damn I feel like such an ass no I
feel like such an idiot right now I I
had that exact same thing at the con in
Miami right except like you'd think that
because you're at a convention it would
be easier than say like a restaurant
setting right because you know every
like famous person who's there is there
to meet people right yeah so it's like
already you know pretty established
right but Conor and I were in The Green
Room right all right which is like the
one part of the con for guests uh yeah
you know for guests of the con to just
like chill out and you know just like
kind of you know have a little bit of
peace and quiet and privacy and stuff
like that right yeah you know because
that's how I feel when I go into a green
room
um but so I feel that's the worst place
to be able to go up to someone right in
my head right but then the exact same
thing he was sitting in the corner just
like chilling on his phone and I'm like
I'm like I think that's Adam Savage from
MythBusters oh and I was just like
that's definitely and I checked the
website just to make sure I was like one
of those people I'm like or is it just a
local like I don't know so I went on and
I'm like oh that's Adam from Mythbusters
and I was just like
I remember I turned to Conor I was like
I have to say hi I was like go ahead
yeah I kind of just like just go ahead
I'm like yeah but and I was second
guessing I was just like yeah but he's
like chilling in the corner I don't know
if he wants I don't know if he like you
know wants to be left alone and [ __ ]
like that and then it wasn't until my
handler was like just [ __ ] gold I was
like oh okay so then it went up to him
yeah because you know I think it's
because we're not used to being as you
said we're not used to being on the
other side of that yeah because you know
like you don't often run into
celebrities in your daily life right
yeah
um and and so it's like as I was walking
up to him I was just imagining every
worst possibility that could happen
right I'm like oh what if he's an
[ __ ] what if he just like turns me
away what if he just like denies a photo
blah blah
of course that didn't happen he was the
nicest [ __ ] person ever and he was
just like yeah let's take a photo and
like stood up and everything and it was
like five second interaction but I'm
like yeah
all right because like it taught me so
much because just just meeting I believe
her name is Mary Elizabeth Gwen I think
that's her name and the waitress the
waitress just meeting her and being able
to take a picture bro that just made our
day honestly even just that short
interaction of just like damn I've seen
you so much and you've had like
indirectly just such a big effect such a
such a big effect on a lot of our
evenings damn that felt that felt good
it literally I was like because because
I've I've heard fans say damn just
meeting just meeting me made made their
day or whatever I'm like I'm not don't
please don't say that you're a piece of
[ __ ] I am not that good but like me just
being able to take a picture and
[ __ ] yourself going up to them
taking the picture I'm like I I get it
now guys I get it you got Starstruck
yeah I speak to Adam and uh his team a
little bit yeah we're in one of the cars
so we're gonna speak to him it's nice
yeah it's really nice guy I don't know
why like I don't this is not from me
trying to be a contrary or not I'm so
[ __ ] cool for me I don't know like I
don't really want to take pictures with
uh like celebrities or anything it
doesn't do anything for me yeah I mean
most of the time it doesn't for me as
well the only reason this mattered to us
was because Always Sunny the weird like
we'd like watch all of the seasons of
all these boys
five ten like I grew up with MythBusters
change your mind but for me it's like
even if I got a picture with them I'm
like all right well I mean I would have
preferred to have an organic
conversation at some point point but
obviously you can't force that yeah yeah
so it's to me it's like because you
don't want to be that guy right yeah
yeah I mean I don't like I don't know I
just don't I don't really get star
struck by anyone as well like I just
kind of like I'm like if I happen to
talk to someone who did something I've
watched that's really [ __ ] cool and
that's awesome but if I don't I I'm
still gonna live my life no exactly like
there is some like I'm not like I
wouldn't be this like every celebrity if
I if I meet like [ __ ] Leonardo
DiCaprio I'd be like that's really cool
it's Leonardo DiCaprio but I wouldn't be
like you know he hasn't had a massive
effect in my life but I'd still be
shooting myself I'd be shooting myself
well like I wouldn't but like it would
be different if I had met something like
I'm trying to think Quentin Tarantino
yeah we're up with this grew up with
this films [ __ ] respect the [ __ ] out
of him if I got a chance to meet him
that's like one person off the top of my
head I would actually be Starstruck
about yeah yeah because he's uh he's
done a lot it's pretty to [ __ ] off as
well
actually actually
it's like Quincy told me
[Music]
just a Quentin Tarantino interview I'm
like oh Quentin Tarantino is just a
Quentin Tarantino character in a Quentin
Tarantino movie you know like it's he
talks exactly like one of the characters
you know any of the characters he would
write and it's just God what I would
give just well that's why he's in his
own movies a lot of the time because he
doesn't have to act that's just him yeah
exactly right this episode is sponsored
by Honey the easy way to save When
shopping on your iPhone or computer guys
I know you shop online okay let's just
let's just get that out of the way okay
how often does that promo code just
taunt you when you get to the checkout
Fields all the time I'm a little guitar
he's getting emotional
I just just remembering that just just
brings me so much pain well thanks to
Honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
Intel for promo codes and applies the
best one it can find to your cart
recently because you know the winter
season is coming eventually okay okay
it's recently buying ski passes for an
upcoming vacation of mine and I didn't
think I'd be able to save money on those
but guess what boys honey saved me a
good job I saved 10 on that bad boy
about 50 bucks you know how many beers
I'm gonna be buying with that 50 bucks a
lot if you don't already have honey you
could be just straight up missing out
out not only that by getting honey
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting the boys as well so get honey
for free by going to joinhoney.com trash
taste that's joinhoney.com trash taste
links in the description below back to
the episode
but yeah like is is there anyone you
would you think you'd be Starstruck
about if you ever met them in real life
uh I mean Adam isn't the only one I've
been Starstruck by the the the first
person I ever felt like that feeling of
StarStruck which I'm probably talked
about uh was um I met obata Takashi yeah
at a con he's the guy who uh Drew Death
Note oh yeah um yeah he was at a con
randomly and uh that was the one time
out of the US uh in Canada yeah he was
just he was he was he was a guest that I
think it'll talk with someone what he is
where I was a guest at and it was really
well I think I've told this story but
like basically we went to the opening
ceremony because we would guess and then
they were like uh you know introducing
each of the guests well there was a
bunch of voice actors couple YouTubers
stuff like that and then they were like
uh now for on for the the Japanese
guests and then they'd list off a couple
of people and they were like and finally
we have the uh one of the creators of
death note or what's a Takashi and he
just didn't stand up yeah and so I so
everyone in that room thought oh he's
just not there right he just didn't show
up to the meeting whatever I was just
like maybe I'll see him maybe his
marriage you can't understand English
yeah yeah I was like I was like maybe
I'll see him you know but I wasn't
thinking like oh I'll get to meet him
and whatever maybe I'll see him in a
distance you know while I'm walking
through the con or whatever which is so
cool whatever and then as we're walking
out of the opening ceremony uh Aki was
just like you should turn around right
now and literally I think this distance
away it's just all about to talk to you
it's just like walking right behind me
it's like the scene from Death Note yeah
it was it was it was just it was doing
the L stare at me
and uh and I just turned around and that
Split Second I just felt like oh I want
to say hi to him so bad and try and get
a photo and that would have been the
perfect opportunity but I chickened out
now you now you experience Joey and that
was the moment where I was like oh my
God this is what being Starstruck is
yeah are they launching this I mean they
probably would have started being like
oh really yeah I could have right I
could I could have so easily just
started talking in Japanese instant
Icebreaker yeah but that I I just saw
him and I'm like holy [ __ ] that's all
about the Target shoes and then I just
couldn't talk to him yeah and and that's
that was the moment where I was like oh
I get it I get why now some people are
like this with with you know people they
admire it's because I I just experience
that do you think there's like a
difference between traditional
celebrities and internet celebrities
because yes I think because obviously
we've been in a position obviously we've
been in a position
yeah yeah obviously we've been in a
position where we've been trying to you
know convince a lot of conventions to be
like look
internet you know people with internet
followings you have to like take them
more seriously yeah but at the same time
do you think that they should be treated
on the same level I think and what just
conventions I think I think it depends
on the size I'm also biased as [ __ ] yeah
like it's treat me normal yeah no that's
the thing is like I think I think a lot
of like internet celebrities or I guess
like the the common understanding of how
internet celebrity should be is that oh
because we see them on the Internet
because a lot of them are you know kind
of uh like self-produced and all that
kind of stuff it's like oh they're just
like one of us you know they're a lot
more grounded whereas like the common
understanding of like movie celebrities
or TV celebrities or musicians is that
like oh they're these people on top of
the clouds that'll never be close to
touching which have been put on a
pedestal they've been put on so high of
a pedal still that unless I am at their
level I will never ever ever interact
with them yeah whereas like YouTubers or
twitch streamers and you know a lot of
other people who have like a social
media presence it's like oh well I enter
interact with them on Twitter yeah you
know indirectly but that's still better
than what any chance I'll get with
[ __ ] you know Samuel Jackson or
Robert Downey Jr yeah right so I think
it's but
at the same time I think nowadays as as
you were saying it's kind of getting to
the point now where the line's getting a
bit blurry because it's like after what
point does it go from just being this
another guy on the internet so then
suddenly you know being something like
Mr Beast or Felix where it's like now
they are sometimes even more famous than
the traditional celebrities yeah I don't
because I don't know what that line is
or how to define it but like I think
there is a definite difference
um I guess I've realized this have we I
don't think we've talked about our
VidCon experience have we or your guys
have VidCon oh our guys experience or
just the one party that we went to yeah
where it was just you go to this VidCon
party
I mean Connor went to this VidCon Supply
so we didn't actually attend VidCon we
went to one of the VidCon
I have enough clout I was just I was I
felt so dirty
that's why do you think I didn't go it's
okay so I didn't want to go it was also
like an hour away it was an hour away we
had it like yeah it was like near
[ __ ] Disneyland and we were staying
in like other Hollywood Hills yeah
so so so this was like the most [ __ ]
it was basically like an in-betweeners
episode for us right because we get in
and we're like okay so there's this
VidCon party um and we just like wanted
to hang out with like Emily and Titus
and everything like that mail in tags
along as well so she's like I think I
think I think I can get us in I think I
think I got some contacts in there turns
out uh she did not that's it the one
time mailing didn't have a contact turns
out the one time melon didn't have a
contact they were out of office or not
working that day so we couldn't get in
so we had to kind of like try and let's
say sneak our way into the video like we
said this at one point whatever you
mentioned I think on that there's
nothing we had I think we have no we I
swear we didn't we have I don't think
we've talked about apologies we've
already talked about your head we've
definitely said it in private but uh
yeah I think uh
so the how we get in is Emily and didus
um and a bunch of other creators uh that
we knew were in the party uh they had
they had passes and basically you needed
a pass to get in if I remember correctly
and so what what we try to do was get
didus to sneak some to sneak some passes
out by himself a Junior's plan go in
with the passes there's no checks to
leave yeah just leave with the passes in
your pants the extra ones then come give
us the passes and we'll come back in yes
I did hear about that is showing passes
down and he was like I'm scared they're
gonna Pat me down like why would they
pat you down to leave yeah what do you
mean that's not how it works he's like
oh I'm freaking out I'm like no no then
I'm pat you down when you get out of it
you'll be fine you'll be fine yeah
you'll be fine so already there's me
Connor and May Lin waiting outside the
uh outside the venue and I'm just like
why am I doing this like in in my head
I'm like why am I doing this this party
is not going to be worth it I already
feel dirty being here why am I doing
this and then while we're waiting we
heard like the most VidCon conversation
you could possibly hear this was
literally like this summed up VidCon
yeah I'm excited now yeah so these two
guys walk past and one of the guys goes
uh so yeah last year I was just like
pretending to be relevant this year is
like the first year I actually feel like
I am relevant and I that was like the
one line where I'm like I need to leave
right now because this dude walk past I
mean God looked at each other like all
right
it was funny I kept seeing that guy in
the party because I remember who it was
right I saw him in the party literally
trying to talk to every big YouTuber oh
my trying his [ __ ] hardest to talk to
everyone
yeah yeah he was just like well he was
relevant you know this is the first year
he was relevant oh [ __ ] if he says he's
relevant I guess he is but it's like
half people in that party won't even
create I'm like
yeah it's so easy to do it yeah yeah and
like you go in and you just like we
didn't recognize anyone because everyone
it's like VidCon now was like a
Tick-Tock party yeah you know
because goddamn's irrelevant I saw some
YouTubers I knew they were my friends
are like hey hi hi hi how you doing you
know anyone here no no I don't know
anyone either who are these people
definitely felt like the Boomers in the
party and I remember I remember like I
guess like the the one big YouTuber I
got like a glance at I guess who did
kind of give up celebrity Vibes by The
Way They Carried themselves was we were
waiting in line it was after dinosaurs
came out and gave us the passes we were
waiting in line to get it through
security and then someone just rocks up
and you see an entire Posse just like
rocking up and I see this guy and you
know you know when like you know when
you see someone walking and they just
give off kind of like [ __ ] energy
yeah so I'm like oh damn there's like a
certain strike yeah there's a certain
strike who's this guy and then I see I
see you uh I see one person like run up
to this person and like it's like and
she goes oh can I can I please take a
picture can I please take a picture and
uh he turns around and it's James and
it's James Charles and he just goes no
and just drops off and that that was uh
that was my one holy [ __ ] what an alpha
you've told the story oh I'm going crazy
we'll find out don't tell me I don't
think I have taught the story yeah I
mean it was it was what you think it is
yeah it was like a big nightclub yeah
kind of like every nightclub and every
uh action movie yeah you're like yeah
you can't see anything it's just a bunch
of people who are dressed really funnily
like obviously there's a lot of tick
tock creators who have like a stick and
there's other people like dress weirdly
yeah I'm like what though
and so I should talk to YouTubers that I
know and yeah I'm bumped into William
Now sort of William a lot William Osmond
yeah I was like do you know anyone here
he's like no he's like and I was like is
it was it always like this he was like
no no like when VidCon started you knew
everyone yeah because they're all
YouTubers now he's like is that it's all
tick tock I don't know anyone here I I
kind of felt the same way when I went to
the otk party as well because it's like
yeah because like otk is like a twitch
uh group or like uh Team I guess yeah um
like we have we all have a couple of
friends who are because you just didn't
watch a lot of twitch so you didn't
recognize any of them no it wasn't even
that it was like because I went with
Ross uh Robert Ross
um and you know he's a lot more like in
tune with like the twist streamers and
stuff like that and so we we rock up and
for one there's barely anyone there yeah
like maybe like other than like Tech and
see it and like a couple of other people
and like Rich no no other otk member was
there oh okay and I was just looking
around and I was like I don't mean to be
a boomer but like I don't know anyone
like I literally can't recognize any
anyone here and Ross was like yeah I
kind of don't recognize anyone here
either well because twitch streamers
come really fast yeah exactly so yeah so
I was just like you know I mean we went
and we like hung out and like the entire
night I was just talking to Tech and
Ross no I didn't go there to socialize
at all I just went for the free tricks
but like yeah I feel like it was kind of
the same way we're like oh I realized
then and there that I don't like these
kinds of parties just because you don't
parties you literally don't get anything
out of it it is it is the biggest
[ __ ] waste of time yeah it depends on
the person I think sometimes I like them
sometimes I don't if you've got a couple
of friends there then you can just hang
out with them
it depends
everyone yeah having a good time other
times you're like God I really regret
coming here yeah yeah exactly and I
think it's because of that that I heard
VidCon funny I was like no I just
thought I'd never been to a VidCon party
and I wanted to see like the vultures I
just wanted to see oh you definitely saw
them and I I got to say hey I knew it
would be like a human experiment ground
of clout like I just knew it would be
funny to go and just watch people try
and to be fair it was yeah like you
would just see like a big a really big
YouTubers well known in the corner and
then people just constantly trying to
get in the conversation he definitely
like weren't being subtle about it and
it was so funny it was cool it was
almost like watching a nature
ready to pounce at the opportunity to
make a connection unfortunately for him
this prey is not biting it looks like
there's an opening oh but no there's a
rejection there's been an awkward
silence it's not a happy place oh my God
and you could see the herb of the herd
of tick tock is surrounding the Sloan
YouTuber
who is now an endangered species
it was just like yeah it was it was so
weird because it was one of the weirdest
parties I've been to because I bet every
VidCon party's like that which isn't
good enough yeah
I heard that every single one of the
parties was rammed and then when we went
to like the Denny's afterwards I kept
overhearing conversations from other
Tick Tock creators talking about like
they like to like used to like the exact
conversation someone was like are you
you guys doing taxes and they were all
like baffled they were all like uh I'm
not doing are you doing taxes
I was like eating my [ __ ] meal like
casual tax brought in the Denny's but it
wasn't like a it wasn't like a you're
evading it right it was like yeah yeah
we should are we supposed is this
something we're supposed to are we
supposed to be because they were all
like 21 I think like yeah yeah exactly
first thing they done they didn't it was
just funny it was really good yeah it
was really oh you naive child it was
just like it was like you bring in a
bunch of these creators who have popped
up and never been to uh because you know
the interesting thing about going to
VidCon this year was that this is the
first VidCon since a pandemic right yes
yes so a lot of the people who when this
is their first time ever going to an
event with other influencers or
YouTubers or anything like that yeah so
it was just like probably it was like a
wild it was just so fun to watch because
it was literally like you could tell a
lot of people had no idea how to
introduce or kind of you know kind of
call people yeah you just want people do
oh my God man there's like one or two
dudes who are like doing an awful job of
trying out because I was just said that
we were in the outside section the whole
time it was a little outside section
there's just one like a bunch of people
just kept trying to go and talk to Big
YouTubers and just having miserable luck
did anyone come up to you guys or no we
were like tucked away in the corner I
had a few people who came out to me were
like oh I I watched trash days I was
like oh
I don't know who you are because that
was the awkward part some of them would
introduce themselves and be like I'm
blah blah blah yeah they would be like
I'm this person kind of like not really
elaborate and I was like oh is that like
because
I want to be like I don't know yeah
because it's awkward if you're like I
don't know who you are just like oh
we're using our fake names uh we're
using our real names well because they
would be like oh you're thinking yeah oh
I know thingy thingy yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think I prefer that though
to be honest
like you wanna you don't want to be the
biggest one there because you you get
swarmed yeah exactly and I I think like
someone said a story about like Mr Beast
going the day before yeah William was
talking about Mr Beast oh my God I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have wanted to
like go to be the party in that case and
apparently everyone was just like you
know how like l in Death Note it's like
yeah that was what it was like right
everyone was doing it and it was just
like [ __ ] why even bother going far out
I wouldn't go yeah it's just like damn
imagine being Jimmy you get sworn by
fans and even going to like Creator
parties you get some of my creators as
well right yeah yeah every every
YouTuber there's like this is how my
fans should act and it goes out the
window and they're the ones too
yeah there's like no self-awareness
sometimes I think in the creative field
a lot of those a lot of people are doing
it independently and not interacting so
I think the thing is because I'm this is
this isn't like my experience this isn't
my excuse me
not that I love more than [ __ ] I don't
take my favorite thing to do I'm a
YouTuber
one one obviously a lot of them have
been have been in the creative field for
a lot less time because obviously Tick
Tock hasn't been around for that long
yeah but number two like did you see
that article that were posted around or
that got shared recently about this tick
tocker who had like a million followers
I've talked about this like a billion
times yeah I know he's about the girl
she had like three million followers
yeah how to meet and greet Videocon no
one showed up yeah yeah yeah exactly and
it just I I guess it just I I guess that
that events alone just showed me a lot
about what it's like having a reach on
Tick Tock versus maybe having a reach on
other social media platforms because I
feel like with twitch I think twitch the
most I think that's where the audience
involvement and engagement is the
highest right because that's yeah
because you see the most of that person
yeah yeah so even if you have like a low
follow account on Twitch you might have
like the most hardcore fandoms oh
absolutely but I think Tick Tock is like
the complete opposite of that right
there's only so much of your personality
you can show in things how many how many
Talkers by name do you remember
oh is she she is a person is she a tick
tocker I don't know so yeah I thought
about this right
you've you've probably watched like 30
to 40 tick tocks of a tick tock creators
tick tocks yeah
it's an actress
like 30 textiles from a Creator and you
won't remember their name yeah if you
watch two good videos from a big
YouTuber there's a good chance you'll
remember that of course yeah because
it's it's long form and like you know
you you're getting
someone to watch your Tick Tock 50 times
is still less screen time by far than
someone watching two hours of your
Twitch stream yeah yeah and it's like
you know you have to start looking at
what that means yeah in terms of
audience participation an audience like
are they going to buy your merch or
something yeah not that any any of this
is relevant to 99 of you but just thinks
it I mean I mean the same thing kind of
happened with like you know Vine for
instance like the only reason why we
remember are some of the bigger viners
because they've moved to YouTube right
and then they made a presence on YouTube
but like how many viners do you know
that didn't make that move over that you
remember my name no no no and all of the
big ones made the move over yeah they
all made their move over yeah because I
feel like with Tick Tock I don't know
singular creators I know them by like oh
there's that guy that did the the X
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
you're the guy that did the Drone video
yeah yeah oh my God yeah you know I I
don't like it like I don't actually know
the Drone guy the Drone guy like if your
name has no like power or no Brand Power
then like it's it's hard to like say
push your name and have it be advertised
on things yeah yeah you know be a big
Creator and stuff so it was a really
bizarre choice that VidCon decided to go
now that I'm offended I'm offended
um that they decided to go more for tick
tock is the neutral position makes sense
yeah I think
the reason I think some other uh
Partners business partners that were
partnering with them were pushing for
more Tick Tock oh really oh okay if I
remember correctly is it because this is
the first year since like the whole Tick
Tock boom happened
just Google like why is there so many
Tick Tock as a VidCon or something yeah
why are there so many Tick Tock I'll
tell you why can't it's because they're
relevant like a baton for like was
originally like YouTubers yeah like and
that's it was you know that was what it
kind of was and then now it's like okay
not not really that anymore yeah yeah
yeah exactly I mean there's still a lot
of YouTubers no they're also a lot but
not as many as before right I think yeah
I would be curious to see what twitchcon
is like because I really want to go but
we're on tour yeah
of course you would have gone I'm sure
of course the twitch streamer right
whatever the most degenerate con ever
probably I've heard so many horror
stories [ __ ] yeah I heard the Amsterdam
one was fun though
well yeah of course it's an Amsterdam
Joey would like to go [ __ ] yeah not for
twitch guys
undisclosed reasons
okay so I had a quick Google on my phone
apparently the reason why there's so
many Tick Tock is is because Tick Tock
partnered with vidicom oh that's awesome
that's smart okay I mean that's why you
tell me it's well it's smart for they're
pushing the YouTubers out they're
pushing the YouTube we're old media now
guys we're old media we are the Boomers
of Internet yes media I already feel
like that without YouTube well you're
just a burger
yeah
I don't know I I'm on Tick Tock uh con
eclipse or maybe it's your dog by now I
asked to have a change
as well as well yeah yeah and like I
none of us I don't think any of us think
that it's the future but I think it's a
good alternative I think for the future
you think it's going to be more
important than
as soon as they figure out their creator
fund I think the only thing is missing
is financial incentive once the
financial incentive is there there is
gonna be way more people I don't think
the money like adrav is ever going to be
there in in the way that it is on
YouTube Maybe not maybe not YouTube but
it's they definitely need a better
system than what they have now and when
they figure it out I think there's going
to be much more of a competition maybe
not take over YouTube but I think it
would be naive to say that it won't have
like a big massive impact here's an
interesting thought right
how so how would a say right now we're
going into a recession yay yeah
recession doesn't really affect
YouTubers that much as much a little bit
I mean it does but yeah hopefully it
doesn't affect them too much I mean I
don't know whatever but for tick tockers
and short form content creators it's
effects from quite a lot because think
about it what's the one thing where you
stop getting money from when there's a
recession
as a Creator advertising advertisers
like yeah like sponsors yeah sponsors
stop buying ad slots because they're
like well it's all rounds it's not just
like sponsorships but just I mean you
still get address right but you get less
but you get a lot less but you'll get
less sponsored deals you'll get less
product placement that's the whole point
of a recession right everyone we made
the recession to stop YouTubers from
getting out here
how do how do current short form and two
Targets make most of their money product
placement ads yeah like that it will
actually affect them yeah more so like
right now it's like yeah you could argue
once it figures it out but now it might
be even harder of a time to get into
becoming a full-time short form Credit
content because there's a recession on
the horizon and ads aren't going to
start paying out money anytime soon yeah
but it's it's getting harder to just be
an online creative period like yeah what
platform it is yeah so I think
everyone's kind of in the same boat in
that case I I just feel like the numbers
are there it's it's I don't think it's a
fad I think that seems to be getting
bigger and bigger yeah I think the tick
tock algorithm is just too good it's too
it's good but right now how do you make
how do you put ads on it people are
going to figure that out
aren't they extended are they gone yes
aren't they extending tick tocks to like
three to five minutes or something but
then the whole [ __ ] point of tick
tock is gone but that's what I was
saying it's like they're like oh I think
that was their way to combat like if you
were to have like a sponsored Tick Tock
for example or like an ad or like an ad
placement like or a product placement
for example that would leave the
creators more room right and if they and
if and if and if these creators now
they're like oh we can go beyond 10
seconds now we can go to like three to
five minutes that leaves more room for
ad Revenue to potentially go up all
right yeah so it's like I think that's I
think The Tick Tock by making these
changes they're trying to figure out how
to maximize the profits for these
creators without changing the Baseline
formula but that's hard because by
extending tick tocks to three to five
minutes you just have a YouTube video oh
[ __ ] at that 16 by what not what's the
[ __ ] I don't know what the full
weight there's a four minute I don't
know I hate that aspect ratio also I
feel like it's just much easier to shout
out something or to sell like a product
and Tick Tock you know where I mean
because it's almost subliminal with how
fast it goes look if if they could sell
Hustler's University on Tick Tock and
it'd be a success which it is then
anything could be sold successfully I'm
sure anything with enough marketing will
sell but yeah it's it it's that's like
the Rarity like a lot of people aren't
going to get a lot of money from this
stuff it's just not gonna happen I saw
one Tick Tock which is not religion to
the oil cannabis and it pissed me off
because it was just the dumbest [ __ ]
video it was a it was a I'm not gonna
name the drink because they don't
deserve promotion it was an energy drink
um and this dude made a video like what
will happen if I pour this energy drink
in sand and then bury it
what and I was like
go on then go on I already know what's
gonna happen but [ __ ] you for even
thinking this is a good idea [ __ ] you
but did you watch it I watched it
because then it was gone and it worked
it worked but I I walked it watched it
out of pure just like spikes it's like
watching a gorilla like you just hate
what yeah Spike I'm like go on go on
[ __ ] do something interesting I
[ __ ]
so what happened what do you think
happened Jerry did the sand get wet the
sand underneath just got wet and then
when he dug it up again in five minutes
it was just wet sand
what the f wait this isn't like I'd like
to think was this ironic no I'd like to
think this was like that's doing this
with other drinks I'd like to think that
he signed an ad deal that was like you
have to make this many tick tocks with
our product right he ran out of ideas
and the deadline the deadline was
literally like the next stage
I'll see what happens it was so dumb it
was so it made me so angry I was like
this is a brand paid him money for this
a brand saw this and was like I gotta
put my my product on this yeah dude
they're gonna they're gonna use that
from now on they're like dude if you if
you don't like our drinks you can just
bury it in sand you're so angry because
I'm like you know you try to you work
hard to make these videos online and you
know like yeah man I hope it's a good
let's pull some [ __ ] Red Bull and
some sounds I hope this is a good video
and then you're like [ __ ] I wonder
what's gonna happen then it was like
never ignore these YouTube look at these
tick tockers man look at these guys look
at this content popping off she drinks
and sand like there's some good some
good
it's the same with YouTube really but
they don't pull like 10 million views oh
that's true yeah that's the other thing
is that they get views for some reason
oh no people just hate watching them
like you're like you they're like why
are you pouring this red ball into the
sand now I need to know I say out of the
10 million eight million of them were
people like I'd probably watch it as
well all the comments I'll get the
comments are more understanding in the
video they were just like you're a
[ __ ] idiot that's some of my favorite
tick tocks though some of my favorite
tick tocks is not the tick tock itself
it's the comments yeah like oh my God
Tick Tock comment sections are just a
gold mine Tick Tock comment sections are
like YouTube comments on crack you know
because because it's like with YouTube I
think we have more control over what we
watch because we have to click a
thumbnail and [ __ ] like that with
YouTube shorts and Tick Tock it's all
down to the [ __ ] algorithm we swiping
we're like why the [ __ ] was I
recommended this yeah you know and
sometimes they're like Facebook videos
they just kind of pop up exactly why a
lot of Facebook videos have amazing
comment sections because it's just like
videos you didn't want to see but now
that it's in front of me I have to leave
a snarky yeah because it's permanently
like with YouTube comments at least you
can like most of the time guarantee that
this content is going to be for the
audience you intended it for but with
Tick Tock it could be for any [ __ ]
audience you have no control over that
at all yeah yeah I mean the the more
recent Trend I've seen in YouTube shorts
recently it's just it's not is this even
a good Trend just taking [ __ ] movie
clips and just like this this tell me
this is fair use you take a movie clip
or a show clip yeah you put the sigma
grind set meme you put the sigma grind
set theme over it completely transforms
what the [ __ ] this is like the most epic
moment in Breaking Bad and it's like the
Heisenberg moment yeah and then he just
puts the [ __ ] Sigma behind set music
over I'm like this this is the problem
this is why none of you are getting paid
because you're all making [ __ ] like this
I I saw something that was even worse
like there's just like straight up tick
tocks that just take scenes from movies
and just add subtitles in the dead
center of it and it's like just 10
seconds of a random clip of a movie no
context explained is just like here's a
10 second clip and I'm like is it
transformative now because you added
some [ __ ] obnoxious subtitles that I
can't ignore like like Tick Tock has
like no
does it have Content ID I don't know
technically you think YouTube shorts
would but I feel like I've watched the
entire season of peaky blinders through
uh YouTube shows except now if I watch
it and it's not got the sigma grind set
soundtrack on it and I'm gonna think
this is like this is this is fake this
is fake I wonder if like these companies
are just like turning their Blind Eye to
let their like short thing grow they're
just like yeah well it's like it's not
like they're getting paid and it is
exposure so I guess I will just leave it
kind of thing right yeah well we got the
I think trash taste our our Tick Tock
one got like it was like you you've got
a bonus money from your shorts channel
oh yeah the Creator font yeah on YouTube
yeah on YouTube yeah right yeah and it
was like it was like I think we had like
three million or something I don't know
it was new views yeah views no we have
more than that was it we have way more I
remember how much we got from it though
yeah well I want to see the views before
how many views and then I'll tell you
exactly how much we got for what we got
it for yeah just just to show you guys
just how little money you get from I
mean at this point like reason we have a
YouTube show it's going to take talk we
have 63 million views Jerry 60 okay 63
million views we made about 600.
I remember I got the email I was like
boys will you let me do the honors claim
and it's like and it's just so
condescending it was like fireworks and
it's just like congratulations here's
your creative one 630 60 million views
and we made 60 million views we made 600
dollars
this is a good conversion rate good
conversion 60 million
it's so sad yo boys we eating good
tonight man we eating good tonight
that belly covers like our [ __ ] Uber
Eats costs for the week oh share between
all of gigs plus that's like what like
that's like a massier each yeah that's
like a material damn maybe we can pay
for lunch for everyone uh for all the
staff members yeah like that's the thing
right people don't understand like we
like you know when you have staff and
stuff and you have a lot of people in
your team helping you with production
and it's like oh well it's just doing
great our Texas is getting 60 million
views or something it's like yeah but we
can't [ __ ] pay anyone we can't we
can't do a business with this like it
just doesn't work yeah yeah we purely do
it just uh [ __ ] follow the truth yeah
the reason we do is because you know
it's we can afford to take a loss it to
be fair it is great promotional material
I don't even know if it is like I I
don't I feel like it's like everyone's
doing it I guess I like to think it is
do you think like talking about future
technology and platforms and stuff do
you think VR is going to become a thing
I know the meta is like I know it's cool
to meme on the metaverse and all that
stuff I swear we had this conversation
like a few months ago
um I still get the conversation a few
months ago I wonder if
our opinion's full of change yeah okay
so like I think I was my only experience
with VR before was with the uh valve
Index right right and even then as
painless as it is if you've already got
everything set up it's just it's just a
[ __ ] I don't even remember the last
time I don't even remember the last time
so I went uh so I visited City's parents
house uh Cindy's families uh and they
had the new Oculus I think the new
Oculus the wireless one oh yeah yeah
yeah it is actually really [ __ ] good
and I don't want to give Mark Zuckerberg
credit but I'm like you have to sign up
for a [ __ ] Facebook account yeah you
do you do I I didn't want to give my I
mean everyone I've already got a
Facebook account but like the fact that
I have to buy this Tech and then make a
Facebook account yeah yeah
I think it's the one that's like
completely wireless but it's I think as
close as I've experienced VR to be
plug-in and play as possible and we are
playing like a mini golf game it was we
all had our own rooms and it was a lot
of fun and it was like very very casual
as well so I'm like damn maybe this can
actually become a thing maybe Mark
Zuckerberg on the right track I I don't
really know why it's taking them so long
to make a good index I mean like because
the tech feels like the best in the
because I have the index yeah
the index one there's only one index
that's the newest one yeah whatever the
one oh yeah I could say we used to be
HTC right yeah yeah because I used to
have that one too yeah yeah I mean I
just wish that it wasn't as clunky and
annoying to set up and like I think I
said this last time until it's easy and
painless to put on and use all the time
it's not gonna seem mainstream adoption
yeah so I imagine that's what matters
spending all that goddamn money on right
now is like yeah please for the love of
God just make a headset that's [ __ ]
easy and that doesn't take room and it
isn't [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah because I
think like do you still go in VR chat
and all that kind of stuff uh sometimes
I I just I can't be bothered to like put
the thing on
I'm so lazy I do not want to be I want
gaming I just want to be standing for
like three four hours it's a lot like
you get exhausted yeah you take it off
and your head hurts it's busy yeah God
Humanity's just become so lazy man I am
well I'm good at gaming I like sitting
down dude Wally is just telling the
future remember
straw well my food comes in the straw
remember the days where you had to
physically get up and change the DVD
disc and not just like [ __ ]
Chromecast to change videos I miss DVD
menus I like and they some of them had
games remember the Shrek one had a game
on it no Shrek DVD one had a game yeah I
remember that [ __ ] I had a game some of
them had games and they had character
what happened they actually have games
yeah I think some of them had games yeah
some yeah I've remembered the Shrek one
the Shrek one had the TVs yeah I
remember that [ __ ] and that was fun as
[ __ ] oh my God are you serious yes yes
yes let me show you right now they also
had a whole other animation where they
just like sang a bunch of [ __ ] for like
15 minutes it was like a whole it was
like an OVA of Shrek did you have did
you ever get those DVDs where you buy
the DVDs and you're like okay I've
bought a product yeah and then the DVD
starts and then trailers and adverts
start playing and you can't skip them or
were those just like Blockbuster ones I
think those were the Blockbuster ones
like this one you're talking about like
the you can't you wouldn't steal a TV
yeah yeah that that had
[Music]
yeah I remember that [ __ ] oh my God what
the [ __ ] is that what is that see I kind
of missed the DVD screen a little bit I
kind of miss it a little bit a little
bit I don't really but yeah you know one
thing I want to [ __ ] the DVD do you
think anyone actually watched
commentator tracks I love commentary
tracks sometimes did you
um I like them on YouTube I I used to
watch the one when with the uh Ice Age
the Ice Age why that one specific
because I [ __ ] love Ice Age okay and
it's like there was there was a
commentary track from the director and
the producer for like 15 minutes yeah
and then there was another clip which my
sister and I were [ __ ] obsessed with
and I don't know why it was this one
scene in Ice Age where they would dub it
in 20 different languages and they would
just keep replaying the same scene but
it was in every single language
and we and I don't know why I was
[ __ ] obsessed with that because I'm
like haha Russians sound funny
and yeah I don't know it was just like
I've specifically remember Ice Age one
I I [ __ ] went all over that thing I
okay Jeff no I was gonna say that's me
in the Death Note laugh I [ __ ] love
the compilation yeah
I remember yeah I was gonna say remember
anime like we used to buy an English dub
with an anime yeah DVD you could listen
to Japanese or English yeah you still
get the the commentary in for the dub
cast or something in English
I've seen that really interesting I mean
I was I was obsessive voice acting so I
always really liked that right and it
was cool getting to hear them talk about
how they decided to do certain things
now it's really fun we don't get that
anymore see I was too young to
comprehend that with my Ice Age DVD I
just wanted to see more ice age I just
wanted more content yeah
I say it's that much I [ __ ] love the
Ice Age one okay Ice Age one is a good
movie this one's fantastic
um I remember uh [ __ ] so yeah so that's
what I realized the the commentary from
the cast or directors or whatever is
always just best on YouTube because
people cut up actually the good bits
yeah interesting yeah yeah well they
tell the stories that are actually
interesting yeah because I've been I've
been getting it lately with better
Breaking Bad and medical shortages
recommended no because I've been getting
them recommended crazy right where it's
just the the every actor from Breaking
Bad is just talking from the really cool
moments of breaking that and explaining
them and why what happened it's very
interesting and I'm beginning like so
many of these I'm like okay this is
where I like it where I don't have to
watch the whole episode where they're
like they don't say anything and they're
like yeah this was a good bit actually I
remember that's why they actually give a
story yeah and actually tell you dude
okay sorry tangent Ice Age yeah right I
had the Ice Age game on GameCube what a
piece of [ __ ] that game was my friend
had that what an awful awful wasn't that
the era where like every movie tie-in
was absolutely [ __ ] awful well this
was the end of that yeah
Game Boy Advance was the peak of that
yeah this is where it was starting to
stop right so there was some movies
remember this there was a period where
some movies were still doing it yeah and
other movies did realize
so and I remember I had this Ice Age
game on GameCube that [ __ ] sucked
yeah shock it was so bad I was so
disappointed because again that was the
period where I was like I need more ice
age and my friend was like I have the
Ice Age game I'm like give me that [ __ ]
and did you like it no it was horrible I
I was so disappointed I went home and
watched ice age
did you play any movie games that were
good I can think of a million I played
that sucked like I played um do you
remember the movie Over the Hedge yeah I
played that game on PS2 it was a PS2
game for that yeah I hated it oh uh the
one that I thought I I thought I liked
it when I was a kid but then when I
played it again when I was older and I
was like this is immediately [ __ ] was
the Madagascar game on Xbox
I could tell you that was gonna be awful
before even like yeah I was like because
like when I was little I was like
[ __ ] you know whatever my dad would
go to the bargain being a Target and
just be like oh I found this [ __ ]
Madagascar game I know you kids were
watching it before is it always the
DreamWorks it's always the DreamWorks
ones yeah me and my DreamWorks family
yeah me and my sister were like Yay
Madagascar
they know they were [ __ ] because on the
under like the advertisement for the
game yeah you'd be on like on Xbox 360
on the Wii game boy Game Boy Advance
Game Boy Color on PC and um
it was like on literally everything like
yeah and you'd be like what the [ __ ]
that's so bad well that doesn't
Madagascar actually no the only one that
I thought was like semi-decent was The
Incredibles game on Xbox I I think I
actually like the incredible it was the
it was guys get all these games because
my dad would go to the bar one dollar
blog
yeah because I was like the reason I've
never played any of these games is
because like I only got like three games
per year so I have to do like extensive
research that's it because like my dad
my dad is not a gamer but the one
console that he [ __ ] loved was Xbox
so we got an Xbox and he played like all
the because he's a [ __ ] Cod bro he
played all of like the racing games so
like burnout and like
Motorsports Grand Prix and stuff like
that so like he would like play a lot of
those games and so he would always go
out and look for more Xbox games and
because we would be playing Xbox games
as well he would just like go to the
[ __ ] one dollar bargain bins and just
like [ __ ] pull out anything and just
buy it and bring it back dude The
Incredibles game was actually good yeah
it was the uh The Undertaker one is that
the uh not the Undertaker yeah yeah
underminer undermine sorry Undertaker's
a wrestler
I never played that one I played the the
original the first one right yeah that
one was good the undermined one was
actually really good because you
actually got to like see the underminer
because he was like because I always
thought I was like because at the end of
the fight in case you've never seen
Incredibles before underminer is this
[ __ ] guy that pops up literally like
lost 30 seconds of the movie yeah yeah
he has like five seconds of screen time
yeah he's just like be all the other a
minor and he's just like this [ __ ]
cool character and I and I always
thought as a kid when you watched
Incredibles I was like oh that guy looks
[ __ ] awesome really I just thought
that's a [ __ ] mold no and then my dad
was like I found an undermine a game for
incredible like give me that and I
played it was actually pretty good in
the UK we had game and there was they
used to do a thing that was like
three for 12. oh yeah
three pre-owned games yeah
for 15 pounds so if you really wanted to
get a lot of games yeah instead of the
two main games that you could get for
Christmas yeah your birthday then you
you do that so I did a lot of that
um most of them were really bad yeah
like yeah oh yeah my dad was also
shoot laser [ __ ] Leisure Suit Larry
games
it's literally just about this car it's
it's a really old series but like it's
it's basically about this character
called Larry he's kind of like uh he's
kind of a dweeb but he loves women like
way too much so you'll just you're just
this kid who just tries to talk up
chicks in your like college dormitory
and my dad for some reason really liked
these games and I'm like
some reason I'm like I'm like Dad
they're not even hot bro it makes so
much sense now why you got into hentai
games let's just say Larry was like
hence
the OG hence I guess I always remember
seeing Legend Suit Larry in like game
and I'm like oh my God that's like naked
women on the ground I was always like
the highest rated like like in terms of
like the adult rating [ __ ] it was like
the adult rated ones and I'm just like
oh [ __ ] I can't touch that and then and
then I'll see my dad playing some of
them I was just like
and you and you [ __ ] and you [ __ ]
judge me for watching hand time
I actually can't believe yeah it was
Motorsports games and Legend Suit Larry
I don't know why yeah the moment I found
FPS games it was over yeah I was of my
addiction
I played like I think I think the first
movie Titan game because I already I
think I've already played good movie
Time games I don't know it's made me a
good movie [ __ ] off what have you play
Aladdin Aladdin on this oh the Super
Nintendo Super Nintendo okay that one
isn't the best on Dreamcast though I
don't know
this is Dreamcast Dreamcast game guys I
guess what's Dreamcast I'm just kidding
I'm kidding okay
um Spider-Man 2 on GameCube
uh E.T for Atari
Banger thank you oh
other movie Time games you're not gonna
put Madagascar on Xbox I did not play
I was not I was never that big of a Mad
again
I was not that big of a fan of I say
dude I'm trying to think if there's any
anime games that I'm what's what's like
some OG anime games because I wouldn't
have been interested in pathetic movie
Titan games I wanted my anime games I
was a weeb
I'm trying to think because I'm like
what games could I have possibly gotten
oh I guess I guess I just have good
tastes game tonight I don't know what to
say I don't know what to say oh [ __ ]
you're playing genshin right now exactly
exactly anime game through and through
that's that's my bloodline inject it
right into my God I completely forgot
about the Aladdin game on Super Nintendo
that was a really [ __ ] good game that
was so funny I said it was hard as [ __ ]
like yeah
I remember playing bowel toads on the
Super Nintendo oh you know what actually
did you ever play Hercules on PS1 oh yes
oh that was really good as well that was
really good I didn't I didn't have a PS1
but I remember my friends playing
Hercules yo that was that was a really
good [ __ ] I think that's this one
right yeah that was that that was a game
yeah that was a game that was that one
that was the most game of all time that
was again I wonder if it was a good game
because I remember as a child being
really good and I didn't know if my
childhood memory is Warped I think so it
was like a really cool stylistic game
you should probably replay it because I
felt the same way about Madagascar I
said foreign
make a video about the Hercules game
maybe I think so I remember I saw that
video I was like that looks just kind of
[ __ ]
so I don't know yeah what's his rating
what's his rating
nine out of ten oh wow I remember it was
a good game
review uh steam it's nine out of 10 and
I was on Steam uh and then everywhere
else like 4.5 for oh okay bro I remember
this game was good yeah like I remember
I remember like Disney games I thought
were actually pretty damn good you know
did movie Time games for Disney I think
I actually have what other good games
today like records I [ __ ] love look
they they weren't [ __ ] Ice Age okay
what can I say like I like too much
Disney properties I thought Hercules was
one of my favorites even though it's not
really at Disney I think I've ever seen
Hercules even though it's not Disney
it's it's Greek mythology I know about
Hercules just because I see it in
Kingdom Hearts
but I don't think I've ever actually sat
down and watched Hercules it's a really
good movie it's the the little devil
guys Danny DeVito right yeah I know that
yeah I know that dude that game is good
that game is actually yeah correct
okay the Toy Story game German playing
The Toy Story game I'd never play this
story what was the game I played though
it was the it was like the PlayStation
game with skateboards and there was Toy
Story in it
except he's just in a Woody costume I
swear there was a Toy Story no it was a
Disney
yeah Toy Story 2 and PS1 that was a
[ __ ] good game that was a good game
Disney's extreme skate Adventure
that is not a real game give me show me
proof that that is a real game that does
not sound like a real game this is the
game oh my God I played this I played
the [ __ ] out of this bro Tarzan on
Escape what is the weirdest thing ever I
played the demo disc I got for like a
hundred [ __ ] hours it must have I
didn't even know where to buy it oh my
God I want to play that now yeah [ __ ]
Toy Story Toy Story 2 on Nintendo 64 and
Playstation Banger game because he plays
he plays man remember that first scene
in like Toy Story 2 where it's just like
buzz Lighty yeah yeah yeah whereas it's
just like Buzz Lightyear tearing [ __ ] up
yeah so it's basically just a Buzz
Lightyear game it's it's just like
that's you basically get to play that
version of Buzz Lightyear and I'm just
like that Banger game not as good as
Disney's Extreme Adventures extreme
skate Adventure okay with movie Time
games are we including the Star Wars
games
I mean you have to well some of the Star
Wars games are all right there's
something yeah what was the one not the
movie Time games though no no all the
independence I mean one of my favorite
games of all time is like Knights of the
Old Republic that's just really really
popular that's just a really really good
[ __ ] game what was that game on the
PS1 that was just like the Jedi game it
literally you just Jedi
the one where it's literally like it's
kind of like a side scroller and it's
Co-op and
[ __ ]
the Lego games are insane as well Lego
games are fun the Lego Star Wars games
or like nutty the trilogy one that
everyone had on PS2 that was so good oh
my God this is such a if you're not
around our age this is such a like what
are you talking about that's all right
they're related during The Tick Tock
segment
you get one for you one for time for the
Boomers now oh power battles Star Wars
episode one Jedi power battles that was
so actually now that was really [ __ ]
good wait can I see a picture of this
yeah yeah this seems like such a Conor
game you must you must have played this
I saw this but I never yeah that looks
familiar yeah because PS1 games for me
yeah well whatever my brother had right
because I wasn't old enough to make
decisions of anything so it was whatever
my brother had and then I would oh my
God I remember you just reminded me
about the pod racing game on Xbox my dad
was addicted to that game and I think
and I think that's what made me fall in
love with like episode one well we're
going all the way back yeah
I do not give a [ __ ] what anyone says
pod racing is badass pod racing is
[ __ ] amazing yeah it's such a good
scene and the game is amazing as well
it's like burnout but with it's like
[ __ ] F0 and burnout but with pod
racing honestly it's it's yeah you kind
of you kind of said it right it's I
don't know why that was so hated yeah
things that bad I think it's because
Anakin Skywalker in it is [ __ ]
annoying he's a little [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
annoying also I think it's like all
again all the old heads are like you're
not yeah he's cute and whatever but he
does turn into Darth Vader you little
[ __ ] yeah listen to your little [ __ ]
you're about to be evil so [ __ ] you
there's something kind of annoying about
like oh oh [ __ ] child actor really
okay
all right you think you think you're
good there are some very good films with
like shout outs like um treasure private
did you watch that one was oh that was
the one uh directed by the guy who
directed Thor yeah it's the Hitler movie
yes yes I know that one this sounds
weird out of context
yeah yeah yeah uh it's um oh my God how
do you explain the movie uh it's like a
Let's uh have you ever seen like
promotion for this movie because it was
like everyone's like what the [ __ ]
what's it called Georgia rabbit
yeah nothing to do with JoJo yeah I
figured yeah yeah
JoJo rabbit oh yes I have seen this
before yeah yeah see everyone has seen
this movie but not everyone yeah
that's weird it's a good movie oh yeah
that is a Hitler movie
this kid actor and that's very good
actually yeah I just I don't know maybe
it's the way that he's portrayed I hate
it when it's a kid movie and the kid is
like the savior of the world and I'm
like like Home Alone
ah is he really there in that he's kind
of oh he's the savior of his will
the world I don't care about his world
bro I might not take this Home Alone
slander Home Alone [ __ ] slap that's a
good movie yeah it's it's a great movie
Shame Shame what happened to the actors
you know have you watched um succession
no yes well we I think we've talked
about this kind of why yeah we've talked
about it why why what did you want to
say his brother is amazing in it
Macaulay culkins yeah Karen Karen
McCulkin is it oh I did not know that
his brother was in that I didn't know he
had a brother Macaulay Culkin yeah yeah
his brothers in in um in a succession
and he's amazing in it oh so cool his
brother's really [ __ ] is he in
succession the little [ __ ] oh oh he
looks like Macaulay Culkin I didn't I
didn't put that together [ __ ] okay I was
just naming it um
I don't remember it's a little [ __ ] you
know this is okay this is the problem
when I [ __ ] binge watch shows no yes
definitely I I I I [ __ ] forget
everything yeah get every character I
don't remember who's who I just remember
that Brian Cox is amazing and yeah Brian
Cox yeah like ever since I started ever
since like the binge watching culture
took over just like mainstream culture
in general like they could be you could
be watching like [ __ ] 10 out of 10
shows but because you watch it in like
two days you're like I don't remember
anything about this like yeah okay
that's a that's a good point right yeah
okay also
finally anime we're gonna talk about it
finally all right so it's Giorgio pop
five right yeah Georgia part five Ed
weekly and every week there was hype
about the new JoJo episode yeah yeah
JoJo part six dropped all in well half
it dropped all in one game yeah no one
spoke about it yeah at all that was like
that was like one week maybe where
people were like oh this is sick but
then it just died down no hype at all
yeah I don't even think it even like
closely reached the hype no not even
close any previous JoJo no right it was
a bit it was a bit sad because it was
like I remember when JoJo were part six
what announced I was like can't wait for
the new memes yeah come on jojo memes is
always going to be a thing that will
persist throughout the death of the
universe and so many scenes in past six
that are just totally meme worthy as
well and then nothing and then nothing
yeah we haven't had there's no hype or
anything and when was that supposed to I
thought they said it was gonna come on
December the other part but it didn't
right yeah
um
it definitely got delayed a long time
soon yeah should I think it's coming
next season I will say watching the
first half of Jojo part six I was like
yeah I get it why this is like not a fan
favorite I did feel a little weaker than
the other parts right I don't know if
it's like Jojo fatigue I really enjoyed
it I really love it I just felt like
your part I know it's your favorite part
for me it didn't hit the same highs as
some of the other ones yet we've been at
half of it I mean to me to me like Jojo
part six it hit the ground like way
faster than JoJo part four yeah I agree
oh I agree totally yeah I was like wait
I was invested in Jolene and the setting
like way faster than I was in the
beginning of Jojo party yeah maybe I
should reserve my judgment until the
second half comes out and then I can I
mean the second half is [ __ ] Bonkers
yeah that's why I just felt yeah okay we
didn't really get anything we got like
the one a few really good scenes but a
lot of a lot of them I was like yeah but
it feels bad because I feel like if you
I remember when everyone praised Netflix
for their binge watching culture you
know they stuck it to the meta they
found found a new way to release shows
and I think now it's just kind of like
people are like wait actually I think we
had it right can we yeah can we go back
to weekly please I kind of like talking
about this with other people you know I
I kind of miss that because I feel like
there's so many shows now uh especially
in anime where if it's like stuck in a
certain jail whether it be Netflix jail
or Disney jail it just it's just a
guaranteed way to kill off any hype this
show will have you talk about bleach I'm
not talking about that I'm not talking
about I could be I could be you know
like one of my favorite anime that's
airing right now uh is summertime
rendering and that if you don't live in
Japan you can't watch it yeah because
it's uh it's it's on Disney plus but uh
not only in Japan oh yeah only in Japan
I believe like some Southeast Asian
countries and it's like by far one of
the best shows airing right now and
unfortunately you just can't [ __ ]
watch it because it's like I think
they're gonna drop it all at once and I
know when they do No One's Gonna [ __ ]
talk about it no one's gonna talk about
it I mean I think like
do you think squid game was an outlier
because it feels like that was the last
time a show just dropped all at once and
just like garnered I think about it
that's a case of it reached such a
global hype yeah it didn't matter that
it wasn't weekly like it just reached to
the point where it became pop culture
like immediate you know what I mean yeah
I feel like when it gets to that point
it doesn't really matter because that's
that's like another Stratosphere yeah
that's that's somewhere else I think
actually for that it works because I
don't think squid game would have been
as popular if it didn't air all at once
was stranger things weekly or did they
just drop them by season stranger things
probably like another outlier as well
right uh yeah but even then I don't
think stranger things
I mean the latest season is hype as [ __ ]
though really yeah I haven't seen anyone
talking about what are we talking about
really it made it's like one of the most
I think it's like one of Netflix's most
profitable that's the problem right it
does really well on Netflix but no one
talks about it like everyone's talking
about like Better Call Saul yeah that
[ __ ] yeah yeah like everyone's to like
chatting my ear off on Better Call Saul
that's that's the big hype show right
every week you go back you get ready you
watch it yeah you think about it and
it's on your mind for seven weeks
because you watch all the stranger
things and then after a week you're like
oh what happened again yeah yeah that's
true right like I I think because you
get you let the chance for like the hype
to build up yeah if it's like a
well-known IP because I think the reason
it worked for squid game was because it
all dropped at once and I don't think
people would have watched squid game if
it add weekly because like why would you
watch a random Korean drama that you'd
never heard of before and uh you've
never heard of these actors or director
or whatever before but I think it was
just in such a unique position you know
I was just like oh there's this new
Korean drama that's just dropped It's
[ __ ] amazing you know I watched um
bank heist career that was really good
what I think there's a bank heist but I
think it's from Brazil I think it is
originally from or one of the I think
it's Portuguese I could be wrong right
could we get a fact check on that thank
you thank you for that over there
uh so yeah watch this really good just
check it out what is it about a bank
heist in Korea
that's it that's it money Heist money
money Heist and uh yeah it's really good
actually
um are you off the uh documentary matter
because it's been a while since you've
talked about a documentary a lot of them
have been very underwhelming I watched
I've watched a few I watched one
recently which one about Woodstock 99 I
watched that one yeah that one was
awesome that was pretty good actually
yeah that one was pretty pretty such a
[ __ ] show I like now now I like it right
if I see a documentary that's over four
parts I'm like you better have something
yeah very very good yeah because you
have no right to drag it out to like 10
hours like there's just so many
documentaries where they spend so much
[ __ ] time just interviewing people
who who have no [ __ ] say they're just
like yo I was scared that day too
because and it's just like
I don't care tell me what happened yeah
that's I think that's why I've just not
watched a lot of documentaries recently
just because so many [ __ ] yeah because I
remember on the Japan trip we all
watched the Jimmy Savile documentary
yeah that was the hype thing that uh
that came out what do you mean hi why
are you saying it like that well it was
live it was hard because because Connor
and Chris were just like yo you know
Chris had been hyping it up a lot
because of course you know it's like
very very British it's a very notable
thing in British history yeah yeah so we
were like and I didn't know about it so
you guys were excited for me to discover
this [ __ ] thing because there's been
no really documentaries about this dude
um if you want to know briefly it's very
disgusting there was this very very very
very famous British presenter who turned
out to be a pedophile and was doing it
for years and everyone knew and never
did anything yeah and yeah it turned
into this whole thing and no one to make
a documentary about it because it's
pretty much like a big big shame Point
yeah yeah television
um but yeah there's a documentary coming
out about it there's two parts so we
thought oh great maybe it'll be like
really condensed everybody talk about it
it wasn't that good it wasn't and then
like here's the other thing
before it came out all the all the news
journalists like it's too graphic to
show you can't show anything it's
disgusting you can't play it on the air
it's it shouldn't air and then you watch
it and it was honestly it didn't really
account any of the horrible stuff he did
it really just like I definitely like
yeah because I remember I saw that and I
was like oh I'm gonna expect to be like
yeah sick afterwards and I'm like I fish
and I was like the Epstein documentary
is way worse yeah they barely spoke
about the horrible shooting they're
really glossed over it and we're like it
was like more about building him up and
then they glossed over the fact that he
did like I mean they mentioned it and
they had some interviews from people but
yeah they really didn't mention much no
and it was like this guy was like that
it was like the second half of the
second episode yeah yeah so that was
that was kind of meh and then there was
this other one I watched was about like
a power plant in New York that like
malfunctioned a nuclear one yeah and it
was just too long it was so [ __ ] long
yeah there's no need to for it to be as
long as it was right and the reason why
is because they just kept padding it out
with interviews from people who who just
lived in the area and it was like okay I
understand you've got all these people
you do not need I do not need nine
residence interviews it's just like
that's too many yeah too many yeah yeah
like for me I only really like
documentaries nowadays if it's like one
movie or something yeah or just like a
single Woodstock one was good because
that one is good it's only three
episodes and it's each one is themed and
it's pretty freaking condensed 97 right
yeah it's really good yeah I think like
one of my favorite documentaries of all
time was one about some triplets yeah
yeah yeah that's great that was great
like separated at Birth yes yes yeah I
can't remember what it's called but it's
it's like it's a documentary where they
present you this story of these triplets
that got separated at Birth and then
they buy complete chance like reconnect
with each other like I think what
happens at the beginning is that one of
the uh one of the triplets goes into
like a school that the that his brother
went to and everyone thought that he was
his brother and he was like what are you
talking about I don't I don't have a
brother I've not been here and so they
meet and they reconnect and then and it
was such big news that they got
broadcasted on TV
and when they got broadcast on TV if
they if it was found that another
brother saw his [ __ ] mirrors on TV
he's just like me for real
and then his Mumford he and then
obviously they contact the parents and
I'm like uh I think there's another one
I think I'm your long-losterone I think
I'm your long-lost twin and it's it's
such an incredible story because he sets
up really cool sets up this really cool
story and then it goes deeper and it's
almost like Hollywood level it's very
good it's it's it's so such a good story
that this could be just a film and if it
was a film people would be like this is
too unrealistic
I watched
um well I can't recently I think it's
like why I shot my dad why I shot my dad
yeah some it's about a it's three
episodes uh the title's self-explanatory
yeah and it's literally you know it's
just wise guy killed his dad right uh
you should watch it it's pretty
interesting um he's one of the better
jobs I think Netflix is on the
documentaries it was pretty concise like
like True Crime documentary style yeah
it was it was like it was it was good it
was interesting
um and I found that it like I don't want
to spoil it what are you gonna say Kai
so I was just going to say that it's of
course
watch that one of the best documentaries
I've ever seen I watched the Our Father
one I've I've watched a lot I've just
haven't talked Our Father Our Father
about the doctor the sperm Doctor Who is
injecting his own oh yes
[ __ ] gross hey yo what yeah
and they all found each other eventually
and started finding each other through
like and only started fighting each
other through like uh like DNA tests
what I mean 23andMe yeah yeah and then
it's really [ __ ] it's a disgusting
documentary that one was way more
disgusting than the Jimmy uh the the
[ __ ] yeah
uh it was it was an okay one I thought
it was okay I thought it was I don't
know I I it's weird for me I didn't
really enjoy it that much yeah but I
don't know I just feel like since the
Tiger King hype died down I feel like
people I remember people used to I
completely forgot yeah yeah right
because I remember that Tiger King drop
and everyone's like we got to watch
every documentary I think that
that that has set the bar almost too
crazy yeah because crazy [ __ ] like that
just doesn't happen yeah it just doesn't
so now like you'll hear like this guy
killed five people and got away with it
and you're like
wake me up so interesting here yeah just
what like this is some crazy [ __ ] yeah I
watched a bunch of ones I've watched
like ones about like neighbors from hell
and that was [ __ ] it was pulling
I want a documentary or was that just a
[ __ ] Gordon Ramsay yeah and it was
all about neighbors who'd killed their
neighbor
yeah it sounds like a YouTube series
yeah and it was I think I think that's
an actual TV series on ITV with no
killing of we know now we know there was
another one where it was like I forgot
what it was called [ __ ] it was kind of
good actually it was was one where this
dude owned a hotel yeah and he was he
had built uh he owned a motel in America
yeah and he had built uh uh in the roof
he had built like walkways to each room
and then instead of actually having
vents they were like fake Vents and he
would watch what they were doing oh and
he was peeping on them that's creepy
yeah it's disgusting is it a good
documentary yeah yeah it's really
[ __ ] interesting okay because it's
like the guy who actually was doing it
it's a crime by the way what he was
doing but yeah obviously um the guy
actually did it uh now because he'd
stopped doing it about 20 years ago a
statue of limitations had passed right
so you can't be charged for doing any of
the stuff oh [ __ ] and he had wrote down
all these uh all the other things about
um and it follows the the main point is
that a journalist is is getting him to
talk about it yeah so you're following
it through kind of the journalist eye
and this guy is a little unreliable with
his stories but he's doing it and it's
really interesting and he talks about
how he used to watch people have sex and
that's how he got off the Voya that's it
you could use a Voya and he used to get
off to people used to get off to people
having sex
mother knows breast and the Voya
honestly it's it's a really interesting
watch because it's like you know it's
rare you get to see people who do [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like this openly talk about it
yeah it's gross though but it's it is
interesting I was one of the more
interesting ones I found I don't know
why am I am I just annoy me for thinking
that my favorite documentaries are just
like the Nature Documentaries no no no
that's a different category in my mind
right right like I feel like people and
animals are different subjects yes
because because there's this because
this is nature documentary that I saw
and I forgot the name of it but they
used this like it was like the first of
its kind I don't know if it actually is
that's what they said in the show but
they use this like new camera technology
where they could shoot things in the
dark and they could pump up the exposure
[ __ ] that was it must have been on um
[ __ ] what's the BBC One BBC the Earth
Blue Earth is that David Attenborough
one yeah
they had the scenes where the Scorpions
were fighting like the bats in the sand
yeah no no there was another one where
it was just about these like special
night vision cameras it's a reason oh
okay okay planet Earth had the night
vision one yeah yeah yeah oh yeah we're
in the sand and that was [ __ ] yeah
like where it's like infrared right and
you can like see them yeah those are
like no it's not infrared no it was
black and white oh no no it wasn't even
black and white like these are cameras
where like if you didn't if you didn't
know that this was shot at night you
would think it was shot during the day
uh-huh like it's like so bright it's
this new type of like infrared camera
technology where everything just becomes
clear so they they get these like
amazing shots of all of these like
nocturnal Wildlife that are just like in
the African Savannah pitch black but
with through the camera you can see it
like it's daytime oh that's [ __ ] yeah
and it looks really [ __ ] cool I wish
I could remember that yeah we are like
the worst recommenders it's a show about
it
I don't [ __ ] know the name I think
one of my favorite shots in just all of
documentaries in like planet Earth 2 or
something yeah um
so [ __ ] good but there's even even
with the amazing shots that they got in
there uh do you remember the one scene
where there's this lizard and then it
gets surrounded by a bunch of snakes and
it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] Heist
movie or some [ __ ] right where the
lizard has yes the lizard [ __ ] legs
yes and he climbs up
and then all the snakes like start to
like gather around him and then like
he's [ __ ] dodging things left and
right like he's a [ __ ] rugby player
or something this is a big meme back in
the day yeah I want to add this was a
big meme yeah and then like one of the
snakes like got like got a hold of him
you're like [ __ ] man it's story over
okay I remember it's called night on
Earth yeah yeah but like some of these
some of these scenes like
like look at that like that doesn't damn
it's at nine okay it's like actually
bright oh that's sick yeah it's really
cool it's on Netflix check it out yeah
check it out watch planet Earth is also
amazing that must be like one of them
but like imagine being the cameraman and
just getting this shot and just being
like [ __ ] I don't know we've got a
banger I don't want to know how long it
took them to God oh my God like those
shots of like the the the time lapse of
like the plants growing and [ __ ]
the planet Earth shots some of them are
like how yeah how did you do this I
don't get it yeah it's incredible those
those are the Real G's because like
that's like they must be out there for
like [ __ ] months man oh yeah yeah
just to get one shot let's get one
[ __ ] shot yeah and be like yeah I've
been drawing planet Earth in like one
day
yeah I'm sure there are situations where
they get the shop day one yeah other
times where they spent months trying to
get shot yeah or where they never get
the show It's Like a Dude Perfect video
I remember growing up though like some
of my favorite things to watch on like
late night too I don't know how it was
like in the UK but in Australia like
after around like 11 p.m 12 a.m it would
just be like either really really quiet
Nature Documentaries that would just go
on for way too [ __ ] long nothing
played after 12. oh really
um maybe one one or two was the cut off
right when yeah nothing started playing
yeah really it would it would either be
for us it would either be maybe it was
just like the the Australian free free
air TV but it was like it was either
Nature Documentaries or it was like old
black and white European films huh that
had English subtitles on it you know a
lot of a lot of the TV networks in the
UK after midnight would just turn into
like static casinos
what year remember this I remember it
was I don't know if I'm completely
making this up well but was there a
point where it just turned into Telly
text for a while yeah it was like it's
just uh
I don't even how do you even describe
teletubs it's kind of like a catalog of
[ __ ] I guess like they used to turn into
these like yeah like TV shopping or not
even as it would display a bunch of
information and I don't even know I
don't so it's just like pop-ups like I
can't remember which networks did it but
they would literally turn into like text
now and you could text like 10 pounds to
put on black and they would spin over
that wheel I'm not I'm not kidding what
yeah they would do this this is teletext
right questions that looks scary yeah
Telly takes this oh yeah that was on BBC
that was on that was on BBC it would
just like display the news or some [ __ ]
like that it looks that looks like a
really [ __ ] Commodore 64 game it does
doesn't it I can't yeah a lot of them
did it or you could just you know a lot
of them there's like buying channels
stuff we can buy stuff yeah yeah no we
had we had stuff like that as well but
yeah generally after like three nothing
would play until six yeah well I feel
like Australia would have got a lot of
Nature Documentaries because I mean
Australia is one big nature doctor maybe
it wasn't a nature documentary maybe it
was just some guy live streaming like a
camera outside of his room got a little
Joy here he was like oh [ __ ] what's that
oh never mind yeah no no we used to have
I remember specifically on SBS which is
channel three we used to have after like
11 they were just for on up until maybe
about five six a.m they would just play
all of these really old like 40s and 50s
European films that were like spoken in
like Italian and Spanish and German and
stuff like that with English subtitles
and they would just keep playing those
that's cool yeah and I'm like but like
you it was always you would flick on the
TV and you would just be in the middle
of this random movie and just like I
don't know what the [ __ ] is happening I
love watching movies on TV because it
turns Lord of the Rings into like three
hours into five because all the [ __ ]
ads
yeah
but uh yeah yeah I mean like I don't
even like because when I was in
Australia even when I was staying in
Australia I swear they played a nature
documentary when I was just staying at
my cousin's house and I'm now that
you're saying that I'm like how damn how
much it was how much of Australian TV
was just Nature Documentaries dude
Australians love nature documentary that
was just like I was yeah when I was
staying in Australia it was this it was
the weirdest [ __ ] nature documentary
as well right why let me let me describe
this nature documentary that I saw I bet
it's not gonna be that weird no because
it's just such a niche topic right okay
okay let me say it's it's that how it is
what it is it was like a symphony so it
started off like with going to like a
band and they were like playing some
classical music and it was a symphony
about rivers
and oh he's trying to make one
and it wasn't it wasn't just because I I
saw it I saw like because I was flicking
through channels and I was looking at
the description of this Symphony for
Rivers I have no [ __ ] music yeah so
it was like music right I know and it
was just like the description was like
here's a documentary uh that is about
how Rivers have basically
um have basically shaped Humanity the
history of like the human races okay and
I was like cool I get to learn about
river river civilizations and all that
stuff but it was just like like
Mesopotamia yeah yeah yeah none of that
[ __ ] all right it was it was just it was
basically a music video with rivers in
there and I was like what is this I
don't understand this wait wait so
there's no narration there was like you
know there's like
there's like the most Bare Bones basic
narration where it's just like one Epic
voice being like Rivers have been around
since the beginning of humanity I mean
it's just like okay
where the river's good I mean I mean
they were good were the shots are Epic
no no the shots the center the
cinematography was out of this [ __ ]
world but man it was that was it that
was it it was it felt like someone was
just like damn I got some pretty cool
[ __ ] drone shots no idea what the
[ __ ] to do with it just left a leftover
drone shots
and it's just like let's put a [ __ ]
Symphony behind it what was the most
hype River what was the most hype River
I don't know they didn't even say the
name of the rivers it was just random
shots oh different Rivers it's just
rivers from all over the world River
just to show you how cool the rivers are
we were documentary Symphony I need to
find the name I need to see this
is
it
is it just called Rivers
wow it sounds like a movie title Rivers
oh yeah here we go River Dolph wood uh
dog wolf dog wolf documentary a
cinematic and musical Odyssey that
explores the remarkable relationship
between humans and rivers this is it
this is it this is this is the exact
[ __ ] wait dog wolf sounds really
familiar I feel like they did something
really famous yes it's on the Australian
chamber orchestra Channel
that's a thing yeah I guess I do not
know this is your culture I [ __ ] know
I'd know if we had a an orchestra
Channel
oh no oh dogwoofer founded that they're
a London company actually
dog wolf is a film Distribution Company
based in the United Kingdom don't blame
us do you guys you guys you're the one
who [ __ ] took the rivers and added on
TV you never know
actually hold on the rivers have a point
yeah
rivers are cool we have a lot of
beautiful rivers in Australia this is
the most you've ever said River on the
podcast
River Phoenix I mean without I mean
Rivers were like the original meta in
like ancient human ancient civilizations
there's the okay see the river matter I
I find it pretty interesting how you
know you had different sects of humanity
spread out all over the world and
somehow without them ever interacting
with each other everyone figured out oh
you've got to build civilization next
Rivers that's that was that was just
like people just everyone figured out
the same thing you know that was just
the matter it's the only meta
if it can't spread they have no other
choice
that's the point though that's not a
matter what's the other matter
the death metal describe surviving
there's nothing better gone they didn't
choose to oh funny River we don't
remember the Mesopotamians because they
started the river matter like that was
just like basic human everyone just
living in the river it's just
interesting that throughout all of human
history no one's ever figured out
another way to be able to like survive
it just like we have now well we have
now but not in like Asian history you
know it's not even that ancient oh it's
it's pretty ancient the ancient when do
you decide ancient history starts
Neanderthals
I think it starts during the first
civilizations you know like the United
States bro the Neanderthals invented the
fire matters like Minecraft it's like
you ever you want to live near where
everything is that's just how it is yeah
it's not a matter it's just what you do
there's no matter what do you matter
because not everything's a meta it's a
matter no it's not a matter it's a
matter because it's the most effective
tactic available and the other tactic is
a dying or not having a civilization to
begin with matter implies that one day
there was like a Mesopotamia who was
like I figured it out
check this [ __ ] out boys but there is
walks to a river and then everyone's
like oh my God
I want to Google the definition of
America yeah it's most effective tactic
available no that's that's literally in
in gaming that's literally what it's
called oh so you're deciding the meaning
of the word how am I more how am I more
of a game with a new one
I actually didn't know
I was just like oh it's the one time I
get to be more of a gamer than Connor I
was like oh that's a cool one
it's referring to itself or to the
conventions of its genre no no that's a
different type of meta that's that's
like what are you talking about we're
talking about m dot e dot T dot a yeah
like a game meta would you say that
again m dot e dot T dot a like the
abbreviated form of metal what's the
abbreviation Center what did he just
most effective tactic available I know
this I've watched enough League video is
to know that this is a thing okay I'm
not making [ __ ] up no I believe [ __ ] you
that must have come after the word
matter was already being used for that
and someone decided let's add a let's
add like a meaning what's the word
called when you add uh each uh letter
has a meaning what's called again
abbreviations
no I'm saying the word meta has it
doesn't matter existed and was that
before and then that abbreviation was
just tacked on after yeah no yeah
obviously yeah but why are you implying
that no no because it says this thing so
it must be no no I just I just said the
river meta as in just referring to it I
didn't realize you're talking about the
m.e.e.t oh no it literally doesn't even
make sense if I like use the other
meaning it literally doesn't make sense
it doesn't make sense with the gaming
meeting either yeah it does the most
effective tactic available what's the
league matter what's the league what's
the current lead sort of a tactic it's
it's your tactic
what are you talking about what's the
current OverWatch matter people say that
all the time you're in a game yeah
that's a survival that's literally
everyone on [ __ ] twitch uses it for
everything now
oh my God
okay to be fair just because people on
Twitter saying it doesn't mean it
applies to history I'm not saying that
like you're not gonna say like oh man
when when when Caesar was killed he was
real
the smoking matter in the 1930s was wild
dude let me talk about that that was a
peak smoking matter dude everyone was
broken like what are you talking about
that wasn't a minute that wasn't what
I'm saying it's like that's like calling
it the [ __ ] the copium the the Great
Sage depression like that's like like
what are you talking about they conquer
the Chinese
the great search
like you're adding a like word to it
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
it's a great search I'm just gonna call
it from that one don't tell me that
stuff that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense it doesn't make any sense but it
makes it [ __ ] great sense
let's just rename every historical event
with just [ __ ] modern works you know
like The Swinging 60s is just the cat
jams the cat challenge decade
foreign
twitch has rotted my mind oh my [ __ ]
that that doesn't discount
it does this it does it completely
discounts there's a reason why everyone
did it it's not because they all look
I'm sure I'm sure when the Mesopotamians
figured out let's live near a river I'm
sure the Mesopotamians because they were
the ones that like started it you don't
know that yeah that we do we literally
know from research on to that huh tell
me Mesopotamia literally means living
near a river I'm just [ __ ] with you
yeah but like but I'm sure I'm sure
there's a historical term for it but we
don't know the historical term so we
just allude to that by just saying River
matter yeah we're the same guys who just
started talking about Disney extreme
skin Adventure I don't think we have any
place
like you're saying this like you know
everyone would have you know everyone
it's obvious it was obvious well it
wasn't obvious they had no choice yeah
they died if they they literally died
right it's like saying oh it's
not a tactic it's not a tactic that
would influence
it's like okay why did people not just
use fire immediately why why didn't
humans not just like invent fire
immediately because people didn't know
that [ __ ] I find it I just found it
interesting that everyone figured this
out by themselves individually you know
let's I I think that's pretty [ __ ]
interesting I I'm this is human
evolution right
new human evolution if it's all a
harmonious at the same same time
everyone did the same thing dude
evolution is just a fancy way of saying
the new metal no it's not
we actually we evolved absolutely we
evolved to create the new metal actually
[Music]
[Applause]
Darwin didn't die for this
is like we evolved because we found the
new metal
is that like in his notes he was like
well yeah so the seagulls discovered the
new meta of having a longer beak yeah no
because because the seagull one day was
just like what if I just had a longer
beak
and then all the other singles are like
oh [ __ ] he's figured out the metal we
should follow along otherwise we're
gonna die yeah
I'm not going to entertain this anymore
I'm not gonna I'm there's no point even
why am I even debating this it's stupid
I shouldn't debate this oh my God
ancient history is interesting oh no no
it is it is yeah but it's not a matter
it also it all started from a River's
documentary a river Symphony yeah I need
to see this yeah that might not be the
matter but what is the matter is
subscribing to the trash taste patreon
that is indeed I can see you just like
your your face and pain as you said that
since
the matter is
episode about meta hey if you'd like to
join in on the current uh trash taste
meta then head on over to our patreon
patreon.com trash days also follow us on
Twitter soonest memes on the subreddit
if you had a face listen to us on
Spotify
and uh yeah I I hate it now I look I
learned something new I learned that
metal was short for something yeah you
know I I I would use meta in a different
term I've really yet love meta media
that's that's that's yeah all right
goodbye guys
[Music]
foreign